[Musique]
chez virgin les artistes français
représentent 60% du chiffre d'affaires
donc ça marche alors avec sa chanson
sont les plus à l'aise que les
multinationales produisent 80% de la
musique française donc à la différence
de ce qui existe en cinéma dans cinéma
c'est vrai que les majors du cinéma
importe des films et les lance en france
mais ne produisent pas de films français
dans le bain du dit c'est un peu
différent
ce qu'on appelle les l'émergence
produisent des artistes on a produit
beaucoup d'artistes qui marche
il n'y a pas de crise de la chanson il
ya juste quelques petits problèmes pour
que plus d'artistes puisse puisse
enregistrer et que leur carrière se
développe plus facilement parce qu'il
faut plusieurs années pour lancer un
artiste c'est un peu le parcours du
combattant et il faut beaucoup d'argent
comment pour l'artiste pour l'artiste
mais pour la mélisse et mathias des
[ __ ] vertes qui viennent pour
l'amérique
oui j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis des
lancements du cinquième étage là ça
commence à manquer ce que vous voulez
dire matière a dit on à 10 et alizé
malade et qu'on n'avait pas polémiquer
pour les mickeys non ça veut dire de la
proximité entre les gens qui travaillent
espèce de d'explications sur ce qu'est
une maison disque rock ce serait avant
tout à des gens qui signent des gens et
qui s'en occupe
webb à ses amis qui fait partie du
groupe virgin auquel j'appartiens il dit
pas bonjour un couloir
non mais qu'est ce que vous espérez vous
d'une maison de disques
ça nous en avait bien besoin quoi
fabriquer pour distribuer oui mais alors
vous êtes contradictoire parce que vous
venez de nous dire que vous aimeriez
bien qu'une chose son joker il a quand
même précisé qu'il fallait un disque il
fallait ça c'est le sait la base
américaine de fabriquer vous quelqu'un
pour distribuer les carnets où les a pas
oui mais je reçois une légère amertume
origine qu'ils sont tout à fait ignorer
c'est que bien sûr ça continue il faut
toujours tailler des pipes aux
producteurs
juste moi je vais aller plus loin dans
ce clip
pourtant c'est bien brijeh brigitte
fontaine vous avez commencé comment dans
la chanson comme ça comme ça comme ça
mais bon j'étais un peu juste
j'étais maintenant quel mac vous ne
mangiez vais à fond c'est à dire c'est à
dire attention vous êtes à côté son pdg
larry nous avons promis goethe
emprisonné sur la boîte
ils vont penser des choses
[Musique]